yeah generic mistake I'm it all taints
softball league shirt all taints off off
me and I kept at this to deliver a
direct message I don't know what that's
me on Twitter side into DM oh I took my
coffee with me into bed and then I fell
asleep for another hour and a half look
I was trying to exercise this morning
it's okay I'll just keep all that
negative toxic on the gene side my bones
for the rest of the day I'm good but
surprise surprise I have two meetings
today and if you leave for one in like
40 minutes
get ready great angle that's a good
angle beautiful okay so we smashed a
bunch of creams on her face now smash
some other just all over our face okay I
[Music]
always feel like when you're running
late for a meeting it's fun to play that
song to either increase your anxiety or
to turn your lay travel journey into
this epic underdog struggle journey you
know to feel like you're not supposed to
be at this meeting but you're gonna get
there until it's okay if you're late
because all the odds were against you
you know just somewhat quick day
delusions untime very telling very
telling also at this license plate I
made her I'm turning on me portly yeah
that's cool thank you cactus
why why why why liposuction Wow
she clearly had a great experience
what's the population of Dix borough it
wasn't me
is for shaping our culture he said she
caught me on camera it wasn't me she
stayed until it was over
was it me i feel like this song is
solely responsible for Donald Trump
being president first a conspiracy
theory shaggy called it first I don't
know if she's speaker is on this you
guys know please tell me but it's also
likely I won't look at any of the
comments Oh like thank you though I'm
back to my first meeting I have a little
bit of time to kill before after drive
all the way across town for my second
meeting cool update oh I love you dad I
love you
empty verbal gesture if I have any
downtime in between meetings usually up
to come home versus I try to find a
coffee shop I said it because I don't
like people I like my dog are you all
next to see right now that's cute I came
home and I have a bottom a cool company
versus Jay oh my god I can't get it open
I said open night grace no deodorant in
this because you smell dreamy all the
time Bernie Barbara grace I love you
Congrats on everything far above you
guys Oh
Thank You Bernie and Barbara and
everyone every search he throws so kind
of you I got you nothing but this
delightful shout out in this video merry
holidays oh wow okay I'm ready to go the
second meeting and I changed my outfit
is something that I thought might be a
little cuter cuz this meeting is a big
meeting now that the person wasn't like
important or anything but this was like
a big meeting and so I just wanted to
look really like young and innocent and
vulnerable so that they um are really
nice to me I love you I hate me you made
it to another parking garage really I
have a couple minutes to go upstairs for
this meeting but it's hot in here
Oh hot in her
under you all face-first into my crotch
in my car in the front seat the fun
thing is after this meeting I could just
sit in like an hour to have a traffic on
the way home yeah my battery's almost
dead dang I thought about changing it
before I left and I did it was really
hard
Emily thinks everything stopped does it
look like if you were really drunk I'm
we're hanging out you like fell down I
picked you up and then you sobered up
okay let's just go upstairs to this
meeting I love you you're my love I love
you I love you hi traffic I'm coming to
join your party
push I've loved her like that television
show Cheers they don't take place in one
location my car Oh every gonna die soon
so let's see how far we get if I use my
phone going back from this meeting haha
well there's something in that car it's
a person so it's gonna take me about an
hour and a half to get up the length of
a very efficient choppers water all
these meetings are going to grace none
of you of ass maybe you have I don't
know none of your damn business I'm glad
you asked a lot of just stuff getting
people to talk about projects and ideas
and things that could happen in the
future maybe possibly never or sometimes
I don't know pool ephemeral and pink use
that lyric to school for cool iconic you
can tell the show's I'm trying to think
of some you know ideas about things and
I'm curious let's do a quick focus group
focus of okay you guys watch what else
did you watch TV do you know what
television is did you let me know please
thank you I guess that's it I'm gonna
make tacos when I get home Oh
game-changer I know but I don't have any
avocados oh no follow-up here's a fun
party trick to play in your car when
you're by yourself listen to Adele
rolling in the deep and imagine that the
chorus she sings we could have had an
owl farting in the deep okay ready
here comes here comes guys get ready oh
my god
hi my camera battery died mother but
that doesn't mean I'm not gonna show you
guys a trick look listen to this ready
okay we could have had an owl farting in
the deep here goes
pick up pick up get ready
I know I know
all right you're different now you're
welcome I'm gonna start editing vlogmas
and then I'm gonna make some [ __ ] invite
me to your X Games events but don't I
won't show up man I did exercise yeah
and then I took a shower just sometimes
I like care about my body but no I'm
gonna drink some tequila and eat cheese
so everything in balance we gonna blog
with Dave great I know so good I'm so
good at this if you haven't already
subscribe to this YouTube channel
because it's my dog is diarrhea so I'm
making her some white rice keeping you
guys up to date on every single thing
that's happening in my life although I
don't know Oh extra front back for you
guys I drove by a middle-aged man that
was very openly masturbating in his car
while driving have fun with that
information I'm definitely not oh
vlogmas I love you